welcome back to las vegas now health
plan of nevada and count the kicks
organization have teamed up to ensure
expecting mothers are taken care of and
have the resources for their
one-of-a-kind experience i spoke to them
to learn more katie niece of health plan
of nevada emily price of count the kicks
and welcome to the show
thank you rocky we are talking about
maternal health and how important that
is katie i'll start with you
according to america health rankings
compiled by united health foundation
nevada ranks below the national average
for adequate prenatal care
we at health plan of nevada recognize
that each and every pregnancy
is a one-of-a-kind experience we are
here with count the kicks today
to talk about maternal health and the
resources that are available for
expectant mothers
i'm going to turn it over to emily and
she can talk a little bit about count
the kicks
and how it can help pregnant moms we're
thrilled to partner with health plan of
nevada thank you so much for having us
today rocky
um we are a stillbirth prevention
campaign that talks to
expectant parents and empowers expectant
mamas to
get to know their babies movements in
the third trimester pay attention
to what's normal for their baby and
speak up if they notice a change in
their baby's movements and the reason
why that's important
is because every baby is different and
your baby's movements are an indication
if they're doing well in the third
trimester of pregnancy
so getting to know what's a normal
amount of your baby and also the
strength of your baby's movements
in the third trimester are so important
and we also
along with the health plan of having
encourage you to speak up if you notice
a change in what's normal for your baby
and we even have a free app it's called
count the kicks it's available
in your app store awesome and speaking
of apps
what kind of programs are available for
new moms or pregnant moms
having a baby can be an exciting time
but it's also
important to have support so it's
important for new moms to have a doctor
and nurses we at health plan of nevada
have a pregnancy case management program
that is compiled of a team of nurses
that work one-on-one with pregnant
mothers through each stage of pregnancy
and through each milestone and also
i would encourage you to download count
the kicks app if you haven't already
as this is a great new resource for
expectant mothers
emily what's the call to action how can
we help you
thank you so much i would say tell every
expectant parent that you know
about the importance of paying attention
to your baby's movements in the third
trimester
and to speak up if you notice a change a
baby's movements are like a vital sign
when you and i aren't feeling well
we want to lay on the couch we want to
lay in bed it's the same thing for
babies
if they're not doing well in the third
trimester their movements are going to
change
and that's why it's so important for
every nevada expectant parent
to get to know what's normal for their
baby and to speak up tell their provider
go to the hospital if you need to
hospitals are open 24 7
and let them know that something has
changed so download the free app talk to
your provider about it
it's an empowering campaign a great way
to bond with baby
and we're so excited to be in nevada
it's a great program to learn more about
programs for expectant moms visit
healthplan of nevada.com and
countingthekicks.org
or just call the ob hotline at
844-851-7830
there's more las vegas now